this is awesome having you sitting here
in studio how so we were chatting
backstage you're from Jersey City
correct yes I was Jersey born in Jersey
City okay yeah and then my parents split
up moved to California and I was five
yeah they went to boot Cosby around 13
we moved back to New York to shoot that
show now did you did you test fur Cosby
shows that well yeah you get like a test
in the lab boom audition yeah but it's
funny I was literally the lot the last
person they saw my agent had submitted
me early on when they were casting right
but they were looking for a six one 15
year old and I was like five five and 13
so hey they had and and you know PI the
running joke cuz you know mr. Cosby's
son Ennis was six one at 15 right so
Dina there was one of the I saw one of
the original scripts there's you know
deals getting in trouble didn't close
like you know Theo stand up and he
stands up and he's an inch taller than
the cliffs this Theo sit down yes that's
kind of one of the running jokes but
they couldn't cast that guy and I was
literally the last person they saw and
then boom you were higher yeah what was
that experience like for you Malcolm I
mean just like you're a kid and then all
of a sudden you were on one of the
monster hit television shows in the
history of the medium yeah it was
awesome to be honest yeah it was I mean
growing up in New York I think helped a
great deal
hmm because you know it was obviously a
phenomenally successful show but we were
living in New York and not LA and you
know had we been in LA there were been
just a whole different experience in
terms right and always being on a
soundstage you know your best friends
being on you know a couple of stages
down the street I mean you know down
down the way on the same lot sure so
this allowed us you know we shot in
Brooklyn and there was no commissary in
our particular studio so at lunchtime we
had to walk the neighborhood to get our
food so there was just a different
experience being in New York yeah then
if we had done that show another I
thought you were said you just went to
mr. Hooper's place on Sesame probably
shooting it right around the block
actually no I did I did finally make it
to
mr. Hooper's place yeah you just went
there and you bought something out there
you know we know actually I had directed
a couple episodes of obsessive come on
yeah bad yeah so that was that was what
do you mean you do what do you mean you
directed it I do it well you know I
started out even I started out directing
like early on on Cosme so I was actually
directing Cosby while we were on how old
are you I was 18 you're an 18 year old
directly at the time I was the youngest
director India and the DGA danyoung yeah
and then a year later Kirk Cameron got
in the DG okay so you beat you yeah yeah
but I study I started directing early on
it's doing like in my own just kind of
my own little video shoots because I
knew directing was one of the things
that I wanted to do to stay consistently
active the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy